mmm steak oh you just entered to the
tournament to play me and you play me
nice I wonder how many people do that
whit Nick good luck someone wanted Trump
house key earlier hmm I don't know I
could play a London we're not gonna have
a Dutch Lacey for let's play London I'll
try and make it fun okay six a six I
don't know why people play it seen this
a lot each six
I'll keep developing I could play c4
though c4 actually justifies a six cuz
after it takes b5 there should be seven
so I'll just play Bishop t3 maybe I'll
go for efore I'll put the knight on e5
this is gonna be very fun very soon
there's ideas of g4 as well play c3
first
if 97 there's a trap of taking on f7 and
yeah they're really trade so if not h5
is possible then the trade would be more
justified but I control h5 I could
castle in Queen f3 first looks quite
nice
or just castling let's just Castle I'm
still waiting for this chat 90 sat on
Knight takes f7 i Poland's not falling
for it I think I'll play Queen f3 now
and just preparing rook a e1 my rook
stays on that one cuz maybe someday I'll
play like this and then I don't know
this and then this and then this I just
want everything on the Kings side
even like rook ae1 do this stuff and the
Knights night df3
maybe eg4 included well i think i was
saying if 97 it blocks I didn't make it
clear it would block the Queen from
defending the bishop and allows the
static King h8 so King h8 is slightly
weakening to f7
it's a attempt at defending in Queen h3
actually looks quite attractive because
I'm I'm considering sacking it might
take like a few moves like rook III and
rook liftings is very possible Knight h7
so box during the turning into a turtle
just trying to survive in this kind of
shell formation can I just take takes
takes takes I hit the Lights
I think F I would be forced and then I
have 96 King g8 it's close I'm not
seeing the win though
and seems very close I mean this is the
type of position you like you don't want
to like fall into the wormhole of
calculation and I think here I just
should make the judgement that like
rookie one is simple and solid a lot
blacks suffer that's six that's six
coming at six maybe then I can sack of's
excited I just fork okay let's do this
mmm-hmm it makes sense to take with pawn
now the pawn plays a nice restrictive
role these pieces are not really helping
defending the King and I think I wanted
rook lifts there's also some idea of
this should be one queen d3 in just
simple means but actually now with a
pawn here I think I am threatening to
take and if I five I just want the song
I guess I forgot 7 and hmm I have a g4
can the Knights I don't know where the
Knights coming to one of these squares
and like g6 might come go play neither
three again not trying not to move too
slowly my g6 I think just Bishop d2 even
though this is still very tempting I'm
just trying to play restrictively I
could take but taking actually makes
black of it safer
also opens a file realizing my queen
probably wants to be here my knight
wants to be here my pawn wants to be
here okay be fine d5 doesn't I mean that
looks typical but I don't think it does
too much I play this it allows Knight g5
with 95 queen g4 than the lights I can
be used as fuel from g5 there's some
idea of knight c6 yeah I'm trying to
attack sometimes before you attack you
just have to improve your pieces
unleash your pawns
okay f4 that's kind of a slow build-up
aha so I think this is uh just allowing
me to win clean material I could take I
take block has to take and then I win a
six well I think even better is to take
first and then g3 and I has to move back
and then I win the pawn I keep actually
win Connect four
okay no more attacking just about
winning upon and getting a better
endgame
that's the nature of like attacking
chest sometimes you have to decide when
when to just go after material oh no no
no I wanted I oh no I let go of the
bishop because I was thinking about
Knight takes c6 that's such a bad move
oh man like I was about to play this and
then I I saw Knight takes c6 I think
means over Lisa bishop on c4 that's so
bad I was gonna have a such a nice
position - I should ask for a take back
but let's try and win ton of peace oh
this might sell out of play that's not
what I wanted though play this move g4
don't laugh at me an opponent's yeah
plums up on time - mmm - do have to move
quicker of each for thing is no a fives
never coming okay let's play h4 just
down the piece for nothing it's so bad
play rook here I mean at least I'm not
down the Queen okay I'll have to trade a
pair of minors
I think the goal if I get the chance I
do want to play off five now if I was
hard to stop actually if g6 I still play
off five we trade I have a 67 because
discovered check yeah the lights and I
could argue that I'm not down with peace
cuz Bach is down the night here but I am
down at night I just went up on I could
kind of miss places my bishop
it's probably the move to go for I was
so proud of my like play I could take
the rook now okay so maybe I mean let's
take the room it takes here I'm winning
again okay so I'm kind of coming back
what's material rook for to Magnus I'm
still clearly worse but it's not as bad
as being down a knight and my pawns are
menacing yeah that's a good move or is
it a good move I have this move and then
rook b8 hmm not sure which work to move
like e 2 or B 1 or who makes a
difference even probably this rook
because if I move this Richter's Bishop
f3 average III is also a threat though
it's a pleasant
okay let's try so my one thought is that
I'll just abandon my pawns and go after
the Knights
so I'm calculating Misha d5 rook PA King
g8 and then something like I know let's
find a square like rook c8 takes in the
rook e1 there rook g3 and then King f2
and then takes and then rook e8 I lose a
lot of pawns while you win the night so
it's something Bishop c6 okay let's
start with oh well it's gonna play like
it should be five coming off I play this
move maybe oh I can play at five
actually I find very enticing yeah I
forgot I thought like in order to make
this rook useful I had to like come to
the back rank but they can just stay on
f1 I just opened that file so if rook g3
King here there's Ritchie to king h3 if
here here here I take and then like the
combination of the rooks and the pawn
it's overwhelming
so I might I might be okay here trying
to protect my rating points precious
rating points I mean okay so if black
takes and I have to choose between rook
takes or pawn takes pawn takes the pawns
are still menacing and then there's no
rook g3 winning this pawn
okay trusting a little bit of intuition
I mean this pawn still kind of falling
those pawns a weak but I have some nice
nice pressure also trying to catch up on
time
I think this move like you might get
stuck but that's life
rook g2 King here and as long as I'm not
getting mated I know yeah everything's
falling yeah I have 600 pawns
threatening Bishop g2 but doesn't matter
I don't think it matters
Bishop g2 it's something but this is
also something I have multiple threats
yeah so I saw this and I just assume
they'll have e7 after I lose my rook
I'll both temporarily be down to minor
pieces at least seven imeem this is a
future Queen there's one check King f3
and then probably resigns hold the game
yeah what was that
was that a bishop sacrifice or a bishop
blunder earlier maybe it was a sacrifice
looky that's why you never give up from
being gone material and never like freak
out like when you make a mistake in the
chess game you should not lose hope it
was all calculation from 10 moves back
yeah it's the worst move I've played in
a while I mean it doesn't even look like
a mouse slip like what was I intending
to do I just I move the bishop and then
try to place it back on d3 if I place it
back on c4
thanks for the bits people yeah of
course like I wanted to take or maybe I
don't know no I think this is still the
better move to take and then this it
would have been cleaner
but I guess Bishop c4 it made things
more entertaining
maybe that's you tuber thee I don't have
too many mouths lip videos on YouTube
yeah you too people thanks for watching
leave a comments follow me on Twitch
subscribe on YouTube I'll see you in the
future